- Let's get that first
suggestion then more,
more freestyle. What
do you wanna rap about?
- [Male Audience Member] Pedophiles!
- I beg your pardon? You said, you said...
You said pedophiles?
- [Male Audience Member]
Sorry, paedophiles.
- Yeah thank you, correct,
you're paying attention.
Is that really what you want to rap about?
(Audience laughs)
- [Male Audience Member]
Put you under the gun, yeah!
- You're going to put me under the gun?
What a horrible, horrible saying!
(Audience laughs)
Okay.
- [Male Audience Member] Or a microscope.
- A microscope, thank
you! Put me under the gun
or a microscope, that's,
I think we've made
the greatest scientific
discovery of our generation.
(small explosion sound) Oh
dear, I've destroyed the sample.
Okay, so pedophiles and
the phrase "under the gun"
from that man there, um, welcome
back, you're just in time
to tell me what you would
like to hear a rap about.
- [Female Audience Member 1] Oh shit.
- Oh shit, yes exactly.
(Audience laughs)
Anything at all.
- [Female Audience Member 1] A rap?
- Yeah
- [Female Audience Member 1] French fries.
- French fries? Cool,
okay. He said pedophiles
under the gun. (Audience laughs)
French fries.
(Audience laughs)
People, in this kind of shrouded enclave
here, what would you like a rap about?
- [Female Audience Member
2] Chocolate chips.
- You're not in that shrouded
enclave (audience laughs)
but, but again, I feel
like you've really, you've
had us in the gutter and
then we required two women
to just be like "french fries
and chocolate chips, Chris".
(audience laughs)
- "Ignore him, we're not
all like him". Thank you,
person not in a shrouded enclave.
Let's come to the, the
very back of the room.
People in the back, I wanna
get you guys involved.
Did you, you're raising
a hand to your mouth,
you're ready to bellow,
you're like, yes go for it!
- [Female Audience
Member 3] I'd like pussy.
- You'd like pussy? (Audience laughs)
Cool, what, what about
it? Let's, let's expand,
let's be more specific.
- [Female Audience Member
3] That's all I have.
- That's all you have, well
that's okay, if you had more
than that you'd be a
hermaphrodite, which is fine.
(Audience laughs and claps)
Okay, and to keep up with
the trend, welcome back,
what would you like to hear a rap about?
- [Female Audience Member
4] Uhhhh, boomboxes.
- Boomboxes? You're very,
very quick and I feel
you've finished off the trifecta
of alliterative suggestions
because she said french fries,
she said chocolate chips,
you've said boomboxes, he said pedophiles,
and that lady over there said
pussy, that's all I have.
(Audience laughs)
So really, you and you make
friends, you three, well done.
(Audience laughs)
This, those are your five
suggestions, I'm gonna say
uh, they're gonna be, they're
gonna be great. We're gonna
turn them into beautiful
improvised hip-hop.
Freestyle, made up on the
spot, I know you didn't know
what was really happening but
that's what's happening now,
um, I'm gonna ask my lovely
band to come out with something
that we're gonna rap.
(Bouncy hip-hop beat)
Good lordy, ah, this is great,
cool. I'm excited, I hope
all of y'all are excited
as well, are you excited?
(Audience cheers)
Thank you, and there's
really no need to clap,
professional drummer over there.
(Rapping) ♪ Came back from
the bathrooms, imagine
♪ your surprise, English man
on the stage, french fries, ♪
♪ you had to pause before, you were like ♪
♪ "You're a swallower". ♪
♪ The tension in my throat,
waddled to McDonald's, I'm gonna ♪
♪ get that, or maybe In N' Out,
or maybe Shake Shack, we can ♪
♪ have a real row, people
fighting, they're like "I prefer ♪
♪ from the Burger King, more
crunchy on the outside, then ♪
♪ soft within. I like to get
it, I really wanna spoil, ♪
♪ Put it in there, I get
a vat of fresh oil. ♪
♪ Never make it risky,
always make it crispy. ♪
♪ If its burned, doesn't go
down well, we're Chris T ♪
♪ It's my name, I'm not saying
Christ, I've got a more ♪
♪ Sweet tooth so the thing that I like. ♪
♪ Off I go, I want cookies
in my mouth, want a ♪
♪ Chocolate chip, given by
Tollhouse. That's the brand ♪
♪ That I prefer, I got
them in the kitchen ♪
♪ Stuff 'em in there, oh! ♪
♪ Switchin' up the bassline on the beat ♪
♪ Chocolate chip cookies my
favorite treat. But if I wanna ♪
♪ Mix it up, make it
more frozen, I'm like, ♪
♪ "'Sup Ben & Jerry, I've
spoken to your manager ♪
♪ Would you do me a favor?"
He's like "Yo I'll send you ♪
♪ A brand new flavor."
Cookie dough with the ♪
♪ Double chocolate, want it
in my little fridge where ♪
♪ I got a lot of it. I start
swallowing it, I'm like ♪
♪ Eating it lots within my
chops, then I pump out like ♪
♪ A boombox. BB, you can
see me on the street, ♪
♪ Maybe on the metro, other
people eat, they be like ♪
♪ "Ah shit, they're coming
and they're playing, ♪
♪ All of the music on
the subway displaying, ♪
♪ I don't wanna hear your
tunes, it feels so odd, ♪
♪ It doesn't move my bod,
I got the Airpods Pro, ♪
♪ So they canceling the noise
that the boombox produces. ♪
♪ I don't like the trash music
they they're giving out. ♪
♪ I'm like "No I don't need
them", why they always ♪
♪ Playing shit like Ed
Sheeran? Or other things from ♪
♪ The country that I'm from,
where we say paedophile, ♪
♪ Get it properly, man,
I don't want pedophile, ♪
♪ We pronounce the 'a'. If
you were being bad, man, ♪
♪ Back in the day, let me
say we can leave it out, ♪
♪ I won't believe. Most
popular paedophiles? ♪
♪ Catholic priests. All of them,
they used to have such fun. ♪
♪ I wanna put them under the
gun. Well I don't really ♪
♪ Believe in punishment that's
capital but let me talk about ♪
♪ The little phrase, I'm
trying to wrap it all up. ♪
♪ Oh, I really hope you'll
change your linguistics ♪
♪ For a microscope.
Under the microscope, ♪
♪ Like a close inspection.
I see your little pussy, ♪
♪ I get an erection. When I
say little, I just mean in ♪
♪ The size, not underage, yes I provide. ♪
♪ Oh, don't get fussy,
don't show the shyness, ♪
♪ You can say pussy, fufu, or vagina. ♪
♪ Any of the words are totally
valid, if you wanna say ♪
♪ What you've got, yeah just tell it. ♪
♪ You're like "Yeah, my pussy
oh so hot. What? Oh no, ♪
♪ It's all I've got, it's
just right down there, ♪
♪ Its a real hick, you
should see a nice vulva ♪
♪ And the size of the slit." ♪
♪ Oh, freestyle rap,
that's what you get, ♪
♪ I hope it leaves your
vagina appropriately wet. ♪
(Audience cheering)